A masterful effort in storytelling and absolutely
one of the best space dramas around, director
Ron Howard's Apollo 13 rocked the world when
it premiered in 1995, and has continued spellbinding
cinema lovers ever since.
The film tells the true tale of the ill-fated
Apollo 13 lunar mission, the Apollo space
program's third attempt to land on the moon,
which took place in April 1970.
This Oscar-winning feature stars Tom Hanks,
Kevin Bacon, and Bill Paxton as a trio of
astronauts who experience a mid-mission explosion
that threatens their lives.
The unexpected detonation dashed NASA's dream
of additional lunar exploration at the time,
and it transformed the expedition from one
filled with hope into a race to bring the
men back to Earth in one piece.
There's a reason why Apollo 13 is regarded
as Ron Howard's best film yet, and why it
won all those Academy Awards.
Netflix subscribers have until June 1st to
discover the magic of Apollo 13 — or else
they'll be left saying
"Houston, we have a problem."
Get into the spooky spirit a season early
with 2009's Friday the 13th, a modern take
on the horror movie classic from the '80s.
Supernatural star Jared Padalecki leads the
Friday the 13th refresh, which centers around
his character, Clay, as he combs through the
woods of the infamous Camp Crystal Lake to
look for his missing sister.
He soon discovers the remains of an abandoned
cabin, and later learns that something even
eerier awaits him in the woodland: the machete-wielding,
hockey mask-wearing serial killer Jason Voorhees.
While many still prefer the original over
this revival, this Friday the 13th is as tense
as its predecessors.
It also had significant commercial success,
and is plenty satisfying in its own right.
Some longtime franchise fans dug the film
so much that they've even placed it in the
upper tier of their personal best-of-the-series
lists.
Decide where you stand on the original-versus-remake
debate before it disappears from Netflix on
June 1st.
Before Will Smith was a big blue Genie in
Disney's live-action Aladdin, he was a bona
fide leading man who played around in all
sorts of film genres.
One of his most memorable performances came
in 2007's I Am Legend, in which Smith stars
as U.S. Army virologist who lives in isolation
after a virus wipes out most of the world's
population, and which turns the survivors
into deadly creatures known as Darkseekers.
Aside from all the soul Smith poured into
the film, I Am Legend also tickles the fancies
of just about every kind of movie fan.
It's post-apocalyptic, it's sci-fi, it's horror,
it's drama, it's a gritty "what if?"
story, and at times, it's genuinely funny.
Those interested in catching it on Netflix
have until June 1st before it's gone forever.
NO NO NO NO!
Blending together fictional found footage
and traditional cinematic storytelling, District
9 takes place in an alternate Johannesburg,
South Africa, and addresses a number of heavy-hitting
themes in the process.
It tells the story of the South African government
sequestering a group of malnourished aliens
in an internment camp, featuring Sharlto Copley
playing a bureaucrat working for MNU Department
of Alien Affairs.
As his story progresses, the film explores
what it means to be a human, and how segregation
and xenophobia affects us all.
Things go sour in the internment camp after
a long period of isolation, and what follows
is a thrilling and thought-provoking character
drama wrapped up in sci-fi goodness.
If this sounds like your cup of tea, load
up District 9 before it leaves Netflix on
June 4th.
This spacefaring sequel follows the titular
Guardians, offbeat champions of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, as they face an attack
from the Sovereign race and its leader Ayesha.
Because it's the Guardians, it quickly spirals
into a high-stakes adventure to escape imprisonment,
and along the way, they discover the truth
about Star-Lord's father, the ancient Celestial
Ego, played by Kurt Russell.
No spoilers, but he isn't going to win any
Dad of the Year awards.
Now that the world has entered the post-Avengers:
Endgame timeline, we're all waiting to see
what Marvel has up its sleeve for Phase 4.
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 3 is still
on the distant horizon, so all fans have to
savor of the franchise for now is the first
Guardians sequel.
And if you haven't, well…
You must be so embarassed!
Don't miss it before it flies off of Netflix
on June 5th.
Francis Ford Coppola's Vietnam War epic Apocalypse
Now is haunting, visually rousing, and valiant
one of cinema's most enduring pieces of art.
Martin Sheen and Marlon Brando lead the film
as U.S. Army special ops officer Captain Benjamin
L. Willard and the highly feared, heavily
decorated renegade officer Colonel Walter
E. Kurtz, whom Willard is tasked with taking
out.
Though Apocalypse Now received mixed reviews
upon its release in 1979, it went on to receive
eight Academy Award nominations.
It was later preserved in the Library of Congress'
National Film Registry and designated as "culturally,
historically or aesthetically significant."
Apocalypse Now is celebrating its 40th anniversary
this year and will depart from Netflix on
June 15th, so there truly is no better time
to revisit it, or watch it for the very first
time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.